every now and then I'll take a hit of
whatever you got I don't care if it's a
puppet up or down or whatever I just
like to you know smokin Joe on over
there on the animal hey they're loaded
Willy in Austin Texas there's a massive
statue
immortalizing the city's most celebrated
resident upon the sculptures
installation Willy said I'll be stoned
1,000 years is it funny to you how
famous you become for the pot yeah
hilarious it is well I've spent enough
time in jail I feel I could have bought
enough of this so I feel like I be able
to sell somebody so he is Willy's
planning to launch his own brand of
marijuana called Willy's reserve I don't
know how cool it is but I think it's the
right thing to do you know if you
believe in it in the past few years it's
been proven that we were right that it
is a medicine that it is helpful to
millions of people I think most people
are educated now at least more than they
were that it's not a killer
we I don't know if anybody's ever died
from smoking pot friend of mine died
when a bale of it fell on it but other
than that so other than that to him it's
worth fighting for and take his word for
it even at 83 the man's lungs are still
able to play upwards of 100 shows every
year I'm sure I like the canary in the
mine I've been here a while and whatever
it's done for me positive or negative
here is yeah I think I'm doing all right
I think the water's fine you know come
on in
[Music]
you